Third question that came in this week, how
likely is it that any president is really
going to pack the court and add seats to the
Supreme Court?
So this is an interesting question, because
this is often mentioned when anytime we talk
about the Supreme Court, invariably the question
comes up about, you know, if Mitch McConnell
is going to hold the seat for a year.
So Barack Obama can't put in Merrick Garland
and Donald Trump gets to put a Neil Gorsuch
next time there's a Democratic president,
that person, he or she should just add seats
to the Supreme Court, because you can do that.
And that way, you know, if it ends up being
seven two, you just add a bunch of justices
and all of a sudden you've got a left leaning
majority.
I think that the risk of doing it.
And the reason it's not been done recently
is that if a Democratic president were to
add seats to the Supreme Court and, for example,
Republicans still control the Senate, Republicans
can hold up the confirmations of all of the
lower court appointees.
Most cases never make it to the Supreme Court.
And the lower court just judges are extremely
important.
And you could potentially fuel, number one,
Republicans just obstructing every single
one of your actual selections.
And number two, every time we have a new president,
they're going to add seats to the Supreme
Court.
I just don't know that that's the right way
to go.
There's things that need to be changed, for
example.
There should not have been a mechanism for
Mitch McConnell to hold the seat open that
could have been filled by Merrick Garland,
filled with Merrick Garland by Barack Obama
for a year.
It just shouldn't be allowed to do that.
There should be, you know, some some process.
And you can think of 10 different ways that
it could be done where that's not possible.
We could potentially be looking at ending
lifetime appointments for Supreme Court justices.
Now, I know that there are good arguments
on both sides.
One of them being, if a Supreme Court justice
is to be truly independent, they must not
have on their minds, even subconsciously,
the possibility that they may work in an industry
after they are out of the Supreme Court where
they are adjudicating a case.
And that may be a factor in how I get that.
But there's probably ways to deal with that,
which would solve the issue of lifetime appointments
where you're essentially waiting for people
to die or to be so elderly that they can't
do the job anymore.
And the timing of it means it's a very ugly
system in a sense.
So I don't you know, I know that it's discussed
quite a bit.
I don't expect Donald Trump to pack the Supreme
Court if he wins a second term.
I don't expect Joe Biden to add Supreme Court
justices if he were to defeat Donald Trump
in November.
It's a fraught and complicated issue that
requires more exploration.
But I do think there are other changes that
should be made to the Supreme Court that would
not necessarily lead to this just persistent
race to the bottom, a race to the top, where
every time you get a new president, they say,
let's add two and I'll select them.
And of course, again, if you don't have control
of the Senate.
The other party could block your selections
to those new seats as well, so complicated
issue.
I would love to hear your thoughts on it.
We will have a fantastic bonus show for you
today.
If you've not yet had the pleasure of watching
or listening to the award winning bonus show,
grab a membership at Join Patman dot com.